hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina we're gonna bring you
this week's review of arrow season 1
season 2 season 2 episode 3 broken dolls
now let's say serial killers be damned
because we got to get to the end of this
thing Ross overall ratios whatever you
say hey ms it boil arrows he's in the
show here where the serial killers great
sensible science story heading to the
meat of this let's talk about Raja bull
coming in here what's up with that that
was really cool and totally unexpected I
did not see that big of a sash now it
would explain a black nurse training
yeah sure yeah you know I mean I just
love first what we've seen already what
she can do right of like that I liked
how they did the the sonic screen that
she has yet no device I've got a shot
that I thought that was pretty cool you
know but yeah totally like I've blown
away like we were both watching like oh
like works on a busy guy I thought it
looked kind of looked like Merlin's dad
that's what I thought it was dead came
back from the dead even though he had
something sticking out maybe so yeah but
you know it's not that but I hope that
we're gonna get some back story now
always black in there like you know
we're having flashbacks him on the
island in history and hope we get some
flashbacks with her too absolutely
absolutely and like I know how you felt
but I know I this is probably my
favorite episode so far it's the seasons
young but I mean everybody liked the
season this episode was really enjoyable
ms think narrows always got great pacing
and great action it just always keeps
moving I mean there's some other stuff
he's probably going to two I mean you
know I mean of course you have to look
at you know the the villain of the week
you know it's this guy yo you know that
the dollmaker toymaker I thought the
Toymaker doing this whole thing that's
Morse that's what I was thinking too but
it's like yeah yeah it's a little
different I mean no serial killer we get
to see laurels dad you know doing his
cops thing yeah who and I mentioned that
you know he this is I think the season
so far just very likable Lisa no there
there moans last season where I just
want to like punch him you're so noisy
was just like so long double like this
year he's just like the seasons very
like you know he's obviously working
with Oliver doesn't know who's Oliver
but you know he just seems more likable
you know he's just like you know he he
wants to get the job done he he he likes
the fact that arrow has told him that
he's definitely trying not to kill right
you know you know he's trying to do
things right and stuff so he's working
with him so he mentioned sue in the
episode how like you know we just agree
with his method sometimes but the fact
that he gets results in young respects
that he appreciates it looks like
laurels
finally that may be that forgiving arrow
Oliver but at least kind of come to like
a nation owes its its it's not his fault
that that Tommy died absolutely yeah so
hopefully their relationship will never
get back on track we'll see I mean how
can anybody not see his face nothing all
that light shining up on him she comes
like I thought she rested adding like
less than a foot away from my look like
this I was like oh she knows who he is
then I'm like no you still didn't see
him and I mean they're too much mascara
around the eyes and stuff too like
walking through the hall like you know
and he loves dad's right there he is
right here like you can't see his face
really you go no that is a like boys
learn cuz Batman he's very maybe when
the more Batman thing this yeah i mean
the mid on rooftops in the night with
his deep voice he is Bruce Wayne he is
Bruce Wayne he's bad man really but you
know what they pull it off new boy image
or a second where this episode it's fun
I just feel like the show is getting
better and that's a good thing right on
i mean it's just like it's progressively
everything up such a little more little
more and i'm cool with like this
particular episode being kind of like a
villain of the week yeah i mean i
thought that it worked yeah it was a
darker time you know with them the way
he would basically kill his victims and
your turn them into porcelain dolls it's
crazy i mean i like that to like even if
there isn't one of the week in the show
it always moves the story along at some
show struggle with that you know like
monsters a week zone of the week episode
of the week and they don't always with
the story long this show always with the
storyline which is something i always
appreciate so there's another great
episode i mean i guess he's talked you
know about Oliver's mom going to court
little try the death penalty you know
it's not good for her but she's all like
ready to die she's like look I accept my
favs red die but that's not gonna happen
I'm especially yeah he's not having any
of that she's just like constantly in
her mom's corner which is cool because
obviously you saw like you know there
are some ups and downs were at
relationship and stuff you know we all
said Roy Harper yes first edition yeah
yeah did a pretty good job yeah they got
knocked out but I mean granted if you're
getting taken down by a woman whose work
with the rock you know right for Ramos
Espinosa League of Assassins I mean you
can't mess her so that is probably the
most significant I think storyline in
this is so crazy they're bringing I mean
I don't think we're gonna see Bruce I
would love I know we're gonna get a
flash story eventually I don't kind of
be that they're at least tying into the
Batman universe you know because that's
kind of like us again like I mentioned
before about Smallville and so that was
weren't things that I always wanted to
see see some Batman it said but at least
they're you know really expanding the DC
yeah I'm just great i love the only
thing that was a little bit off with
this episode's not bad i mean it's just
the island stuff i think it was too
quick like they would flash the island
you know you see him and destro doing
their thing like flashback and they're
under attack and they flashed regular
attack and now we know the locked up in
a boat you know it looks that they do a
good job they're gonna explain the whole
story but is this yeah it was almost too
quick like I never feel I could get
settled in with the islands I felt like
there were some flashbacks it almost
seemed a little unnecessary there was a
scene where you see Deathstroke and
Oliver they're walking on the side of
that mountain running he's talking about
how like you know you can't really grow
too attached to people it falls and I
mean I get what they were trying to say
and stuff you know but at the same time
it just it was one of those quick little
flashbacks it just seemed like it wasn't
really necessary you know and we'll see
what happens with desk jockey saw his
hands like on fire hopefully he's okay
we'll see what happens but uh another
great episode this week you know if you
see where it goes i mean please share
your thoughts with us what do you think
with the whole League of Assassins you
know and now go and all these like
what's gonna have what that it's really
cool so happy black Canary's in it so as
always you know come chat with us at the
think you're calm you can also find us
on youtube with a youtube channel here
which is a think you're pro we're also
on Twitter here when I come shower with
dennis michael myself we're at think
hero personally i'm at griffin de and
i'm at mr. michael Alexis you'll also
find us on facebook at facebook.com
slash think your fans
you